let me return to our friend Eric
Weinstein for a question that I would
ask anyway but let me let's have a
non-russian ask the Russian question
um
ask him about the Russian concepts of
friendship science gender and love
versus the American
you can um so there is a there is a deep
Romanticism that you have
that runs your book love and math
is is part of that's something you've
picked up from the Russian culture
what can you speak to that uh fueled
both your fascination with math and your
fascination no your um
your prioritization of The Human
Experience of Love hmm
good question I definitely there is some
influence of the Russian culture Russian
literature perhaps you know
but also you know like there are so many
things
um how do you how do we develop certain
sensibilities like why do we care about
this and not that like why do I care for
instance about like you said
about this romantic ideals so to speak
of mathematics that's certainly not
something that is automatic you know
some people care about it some people
don't and I'm not saying it is Superior
or inferior it's just how my composition
my psychological composition is like
that
and
it's an interesting question like what
is the cause of it so I think that
we cannot really know but there are some
aspects of it of course the experiences
life experiences are
um
upbringing family like I was you know I
was surrounded by Love by my parents on
the one hand but in one on the other
side uh perhaps they were a little
overprotective of me so I was kind of
like
you know
um
too much kind of like taking taken care
of so then when I
had it develop certain sensitivity but
was kind of not ready for the challenges
the real world of the real world so then
that struggle and that and then being
lost
and then being able to overcome and to
learn and then if you do in Universe if
you don't lose you don't appreciate
maybe but sometimes when we lose
something and then regain it then we
cherish it to appreciate and then become
something important also uh various
um difficulties you know the upsetting
experiences or one could say traumatic
experiences
growing up you know in the Soviet Union
that was not uh a walk in the park you
know it was there were a lot of issues
there
um that I had to go through and
and then if it doesn't break you make
you stronger but in my case
what happened was that you know
some for some of it it took me 30 years
to really come to terms with it and to
really understand what happened
it gave me this motivation
um to to strive to become a
mathematician which maybe I wouldn't
have otherwise it charged me supercharge
me I'm talking about for instance the
experience with exam
at Moscow University can you take me
through that experience so
this is 1984 we spoke about Orwell
earlier and
I was applying to Moscow University
mathematics Department it's called
Muhammad
which is like for people who don't know
like the place it was the only place to
study pure mathematics in Moscow period
but also but also if there's one of the
great places on Earth and it's like a
huge building this you know this
monolith of a building of Moscow
University
so because as I said you know a year
earlier you've gain if gaining which
converted me into math capitalizing on
my love for physical quantum physics and
so we I spent a whole year studying with
him and I was already kind of at the
level of I know
some in some subjects the level of like
early graduate Graduate Studies
so it seemed like it would be a breeze
to go to get into Moscow University
but in fact little did I know that
there was a
a policy of anti-Semitism where students
like me would be failed by special
examiners
mostly during the oral exam with
mathematics but
occasionally would be written tests and
stuff
now my father is Jewish
by Blood it was not religious his family
was not religious my mom is Russian
and but I was since my last name was my
father's name so it was very easy too
to read what my nationality was
and so there was this can you imagine
there were special people who would
screen up applicants who would put aside
the files of the undesirables there
would be special examiners who were
actually professors at this University
who would be designated as
those who would take the exam from those
undesirables it was it's almost comical
when you look back now and also like
questions why there was no reason other
than just hatred of the other that's how
I see it and just to give a little bit
more color so
because you mentioned nationality it's a
little uh Quirk that perhaps gives an
insight to the bigger system that the
nationality listed on your birth
certificate when you're Jewish is Jewish
and when you're non-jewish is this is
Russian for me it was Russian so first
of all in this in the inner part
everybody has an internal passport
and there you have first name petronomic
name
last name
date of birth so these are four and the
fifth colon
is nationality
which comes from the nationality of the
parents and so on in my case was written
Russian because my mom was Russian but
it didn't save me
because that was my dad's last name
and so
so anyway this was a a toughest
experience that I had up until that
point
and there was these two people who came
into the room where I was the only
undesirable all other kids were being
questioned by other examiners but they
told me that we could not uh question
you we're waiting for special examiners
so I was like oh
something's food and so these two guys
came and for four hours basically and
were asking me questions which were not
in the program and so on but you know I
was a kid I was 16 years old I tried to
answer the best I can but it was a setup
it's been documented since then there
are even lists of problems
that were given to undesirables in those
days in my year
um no no Jewish applicants as far as I
know Jewish by this metric
were accepted so then I had to go to
this um
there was one school technical school in
Moscow
for which was the institute for oil and
gas exploration which had a Applied
Mathematics program
and that's where me and many of my many
of the kids who were not accepted to
Moscow University ended up
and so
but the point is so and then I was I was
so motivated by this because I went to
show those guys you know
that within five years less than five
years I got a letter from the president
of Harvard University
inviting me as a visiting Professor to
Harvard I was 21 I was barely 21 because
I already did some research in the
meantime that's how motivated I was you
know so but the interesting aspect of it
is that for for for the longest time
afterwards I was telling myself a story
that nothing really happened
it wasn't so bad okay so I was failed
but I knew that I was going to succeed
it was 30 years later
that I finally
got to meet that boy that 16 year old
that I
that I neglected this time and I
realized that he died that it was a
crushing blow the Innocence
not just instance because there was no
way it looked like there was no way I
could become a mathematician because if
I don't if you don't accept me there
it's over I didn't know that I could
actually find this striving applied math
program and then eventually somebody
would take me under his wing and so on
and then could move to the United States
this was not in the realm of
possibilities
so in other words I could there was
nothing to look forward to
it was clear that it's over I cannot
I cannot do what I love
and so when I finally
when I finally connected to that boy oh
my God I was a totally different
experience all the pain and all the
trauma
came to the surface
and it was
a kind of a tsunami
I didn't I wasn't sure I would survive
this so it was so hard
and what happened was I was invited to
to give a talk about this in New York
it was kind of a spoken word event
uh about science but like personal
experiences related to science this was
almost a year after
my book came out
in my book
one of the first chapters is a chapter
about this experience
but what I realized now is that I wrote
it from the third person perspective
I knew the facts
but I was not emotionally connected to
that experience however since I wanted
to write the book and to connect to my
readers I allowed the boy to write it
so a lot of people were touched by it
and they would people would say wow that
chapter you know it really got a lot of
resonance it was translated into another
language even before the book was
published
I was surprised by this
because I didn't know yet so the adult
Edward was not yet in touch but the book
gave the outlet
to the child
so
and that kind of
started the process
so finally
um
almost a year later I'm in New York in
this
at this event and the night before
I'm in my hotel room and I was like okay
what am I going to talk about tomorrow
and I take a piece of paper it's just
you know my usual like preparation you
know for things and then suddenly I have
this Vision that I will walk up to the
microphone tomorrow and I will just
start crying
and
I'm just like
but by that time I already had an
Insight that it's possible to have that
kind of a splitting kind of dissociation
things were happening quickly there was
someone in my life who explained to me
this idea that
some things are under the radar of
awareness but they may still influence
you and a lot of that could be connected
to some experiences in your childhood so
I was kind of ready for it from
different angles but I was so surprised
because I was like what is there to
remember I know I know everything so
then my inner voice says all right then
you have nothing to worry about
so we'll go tomorrow
and you will speak about this and if you
start crying it's not a problem I was
like no I don't want to cry in front of
people
I want to find out what it is what
happened
and I sat on my bed closed my head
and it came
so
it's hard to describe so this is what
and the sheer energy of it and how much
effort it took to suppress it actually
for all these years how much effort it
took to build that to the pan series I
would say in Russian you know that that
hardcore you know around myself yeah so
that and the thing later I realized
there were moments when it could come
out
and for instance I developed this fear
of public speaking and all kinds of
little things that I now feel more
connected so anyway
I saw what happened now Through The Eyes
of that child I saw how difficult it was
how crushed he was
and it looked completely hopeless and I
felt like what's the point of living now
for me now that I know how cruel this
world is which I didn't realize before
because I prefer to wear this pink you
know the the rose Rose Colored Glasses
but then something happened it's so
strange
it's like you feel that inside of you
there is this dead child and it is
incredibly sad I mean it's like
I can't even describe it but suddenly he
comes alive and suddenly it's like
oh he's here and I and I got a little
talk with him and I said look you know I
know and now and thank you I'm so sorry
that I neglected you for so long you
know I didn't know
thank you
for doing this and it's almost like you
know I felt like the image came to mind
is like a fallen soldier like you leave
a fallen soldier on the battlefield a
wounded soldier and then you come back
to take him with you
and
and I said but look look what we have
done look at us now it was not in vain
we are doing okay
and it's kind of almost just like
holding
holding holding that
child and that
that sense of who I am you know and
feeling it so
the next day
I went to the microphone and I let him
speak for the first time
about his experience in his own voice
it was incredible people were crying and
afterwards came up to me and started
sharing stories and so on because it is
a story it's a universal story it's
archetypal story
it's the story of rejection and
being treated unfairly
we all know it and I think it's so
important to realize that
it's so it's possible to revisit those
moments it's possible to reconnect to
our little ones it's possible to bring
them back
and we are better for it because this
would change my life this experience
then they were then suddenly it's like a
floodgates there were many other things
that came
that's when I became
interested in the dimensions of
imagination and intuition and so on
because suddenly I realized that I was
deprived of those of that possibility of
looking at the World Through The Eyes of
a child because that child was frozen in
time it was I was not connected to him
but suddenly he's with me and he's like
almost like opens his doors and says
look at
look
so
if I could ask you
about there's a difficult idea here
there's a tension I've interacted with a
few folks in my personal life and in
general that have lived through uh this
experience of unfairness and cruelty in
the world as young
people
and
what wisdom do you draw from
the the the the action you took of not
acknowledging that you're a victim to
Cruelty but instead just working your
ass off working harder
and then this the flip side of that is
you eventually reconnecting with the
cruelty that you experience because if
you did that early on I was not ready
for it it is a defense mechanism I could
be I could have come you know there were
kids who commit suicide after this
experience I could have commit suicide
because it's too much
and it is well known afterwards of
course I became aware of all the
literature about childhood trauma and so
on and I've I've been I've been speaking
publicly about it since then too and so
you know it is well-known issue and
well-known
um
kind of a universal phenomenon I think
that interesting enough
even though one now I see a lot of
discussion of it now that my eyes are
open but somehow before I didn't see it
so that which also shows you how our
confirmation bias kind of like how we
screen ourselves how we turn the Blind
Eye to things which do not confirm our
views or for which we are not yet ready
and by the way nobody should push to do
it too soon I'm glad I I developed
certain 40 a certain strengths
I was confident
um I was strong to withstand this and if
I weren't who knows how it could turn
out so it is a very subtle kind of
alchemical process
which I don't think there is a recipe
there's a formula
the reason I'm talking about this is
just to share this experience because I
think that the only thing we can do in
this in some sense is to share with each
other because then we can find
for instance if somebody
shared with me
it would naturally Lead Me Maybe to get
closer to that to kind of understanding
it's really just personal stories it's
not
obviously there is a there is a
component where professionals could be
involved professional therapists and so
on in my case it somehow happened
miraculously well I did have support but
not not from professional therapists but
from like dear friends
so I did I did have you didn't you do
need I had somebody at the time who
basically held my hand and through this
experience yes it was invaluable and it
could not be done otherwise
so I think it's very common and here's
the thing
I would not do it in any other way
when you when I reconnected
and I saw all the horrors and so on but
I also was able to see
that my examiners were victims
of Their Own
situation that they became they fell for
this
bogus
series or maybe it was more of a issue
of career advancement or something and
I was realized they must have suffered
as well because they must have had some
kind of consciousness of conscience
about it that acting in this way towards
sort of
basically kids you know
so it's not it wasn't pretty from their
point of view so I could forgive them
and I could like also appreciate what a
what a boost of energy it gave me yeah
if I was accepted and I was just where I
was a first-year student I lived I would
live in a dorm because I was in the you
know I'd be probably partying and
drinking and well who knows what maybe I
wouldn't even become a mathematician
but this
focused me like a laser without me even
thinking about it it just happened I
just I couldn't do I didn't care about
anything but doing mathematics and it
paid off you know it changed my life so
was it good or bad
Paradox
seems like life is full of those